[Musik]
Tatort Deutschland die crime Doku von
Bild herzlich willkommen zu einer Reise
in die Vergangenheit und in ein Land das
es nicht mehr gibt ich bin Tony Haier
und ich bin Mirko Kasimir und damit
herzlich willkommen bei Tatort
Deutschland bei uns geht es heute um
eine sehr dramatische Zeit in der
Geschichte der
und um einen bis heute rätselhaften Mord
der sich im Windschatten dieser
Geschehnisse ereignet hat genau und
dafür reisen wir ins Jahr
[Musik]
1971 im Westen sorgt der Vietnamkrieg
für Streit und Demonstrationen
allerdings beginnen die USA in diesem
Jahr schon mit einem Rückzug auf Raten
und die Enthüllungen der pentagonakten
zum Krieg deen das politische Ende von
Präsident Nixon ein in Chroniken aus
diesem Jahr findet sich aber auch
wirklich kurioses z.B sind langharm bei
westdeutschen Männern so verbreitet dass
die Bundeswehr schließlich ihre
Verordnung über Frisuren lockert in der
DDR dagegen hat man ein paar ernstere
[Musik]
[Applaus]
sorgen Mann der einer der dreistesten
Lügen des Kalten Krieges weltberühmt
gemacht hat Herr Vorsitzender bedeutet
die Bildung einer freien Stadt ihrer
Meinung nach dass die Staatsgrenze am
Brandenburger Tor errichtet wird und
sind sie entschlossen dieser Tatsache
mit allen Konsequenzen Rechnung zu
tragen ich verstehe ihrre Frage so dass
es Menschen Westdeutschland gibt die
wünschen dass wir die Bauarbeiter der
hauptstä mobilisieren um meine Mauer
aufzurichten ja
äh mir ist nicht bekannt dass solche
Absicht besteht dass ich die Bauarbeiter
in der Hauptstadt hauptsächlich mit
Wohnungsbau beschäftigen und ihre
Arbeitskraft dafür voll ausgenutzt wird
voll eingesetzt
wird niemand hat die Absicht eine Mauer
zuwiichten
1971 ist die Mauer fast 10 Jahre alt die
Abwanderung aus der DDR konnte zwar
gestoppt werden aber die Wirtschaft des
Landes steckt in einer tiefen Krise
unter anderem fehlen Rohstoffe aus der
Sowjetunion und hinter den Kulissen wird
an Ulbrichts Stuhl gesägt Rädelsführer
ist ein Typ mit einer wie manche sagen
einschläfernden Stimme die enge
Verbundenheit unser Arbeiter und aller
werkdäte mit ihren Soldaten und ihren
Grenzern mit dem Volkspolizisten und den
Genossen der Staatssicherheit prägt
unauslöschlich den Charakter unserer
bewaffen Organe als macht Instrumente
des Arbeiter und bauenstaates für den
stets zuverlässigen Schutz des
Sozialismus und des Friedens honniker
gegen ulbrecht dieser Machtkampf spitzt
sich in diesem Frühling zu und das
obwohl der Ältere den jüngeren früher
stets gefördert hat ohne die
Unterstützung Ulbrichts hätte honniker
keine Karriere in der SED machen können
das gilt für die Anfänge im Exil in der
UdSSR genauso für den Aufstand in der
DDR 19
153 damals waren viele junge Leute aus
honikers Jugendorganisation FDJ unter
den Demonstranten trotzdem hielt
Ulbricht an ihm fest aber 1971 ist das
Tischtuch zwischen den beiden
zerschnitten mitten in der
Wirtschaftskrise der DDR legt sich
Ulbricht mit der Sowjetunion an startet
Alleingänge im Umgang mit dem Westen und
gibt Moskau gegenüber den Besserwisser
der 19 Jahre jüngere honiker mit der
markanten Hornbrille sucht den
Schulterschluss mit Staatschef brenev er
plant den Sturz des alten
Weggefährten zur gleichen Zeit schreckt
ein merkwürdiger Kriminalfall die DDR
Sicherheitskräfte auf der Fall Mischner
von dem wir euch heute erzählen wollen
ob er überhaupt mit der großen Politik
zu tun hat das ist durchaus fraglich man
muss auch dazu sagen insgesamt ist die
Quellenlage in diesem Fall längst nicht
so üppig wie bei anderen
Kriminalfällen die Geschichte von W
Mischner seiner Frau Renate und dem
möglichen Zusammenhang zur Politik
findet sich im Wesentlichen in einem
sehr spannenden Artikel des Journalisten
Georg Mascolo der damals beim Spiegel
gearbeitet hat später leitete er unter
anderem die gemeinsame Recherche von NDR
WDR und Süddeutscher Zeitung einzelne
Nachweise finden sich außerdem in den
Büchern die Kriminalgeschichte der DDR
von Klaus Bing und die SED in der ERA
honika von Andreas
malicha ein Hinweis findet sich außerdem
in der Liste von Personen die in der DDR
hingerichtet wurden 26 September
1992 Wolfgang Mischner zum Tode
verurteilt und hingerichtet in Leipzig
durch unerwarteten
nahschuss von diesem Urteil und seiner
Vollstreckung wusste die Öffentlichkeit
in der DDR aber bis zum Ende gar nichts
das wenige das bekannt war dass er aus
wie eine Beziehungstat eine ganz
besonders grausame allerding
im Mai 1971 wird in einem Waldstück
nördlich von Berlin die Leiche einer
jungen Frau gefunden sie ist übel
zugerichtet jemand hat ihr von hinten in
den Kopf geschossen sie mit einem Beil
verletzt und
gewirkt es handelt sich um die 30 Jahre
alte Renate Mischner und der Fundort
liegt nahe der Siedlung Wandlitz in der
die Creme D la Creme der DDR Führung in
schicken Häusern und Willen haust für
die Öffentlichkeit bleibt der Fall nicht
nur ungelöst er wird noch dubioser auch
Renates Mann Wolfgang gilt wenig später
als vermisst mehr als ein Jahr später
wird sein Tod vermeldet ein
Gerichtsmediziner attestiert ihm einen
Blutdruck bedingten Herztod sowie einen
Hirnschlag beides aufgrund von Diabetes
das Ehepaar Mischner hinterlässt zwei
kleine Söhne die in einem Heim im
brandenburgischen Eisenhüttenstadt
untergebracht werden Ihnen und allen
anderen wird erzählt dass die Eltern bei
einem Autounfall gestorben sind etwas
anderes als eine Tragödie würde auch
schlecht passen denn die mners waren
eine sozialistische Traumfamilie
Wolfgang macht eine Lehre in der
Metallverarbeitung und wird später von
der Stasi angeworben er bringt es bis
zum Oberleutnant Renate ist
Näherin was die Öffentlichkeit erst nach
dem Untergang der DDR erfährt Wissen
mners Kollegen bei der Stasi und die
Volkspolizei damals von Anfang an Renate
wurde von ihrem eigenen Mann getötet und
die Beziehungstat ist gleichzeitig ein
hochbrisanter
Skandal es ist Mischner selbst dessen
Aussagen diesen Fall so explosiv machen
in den Verhören nach dem Blutbad erzählt
er mal von einem beziehungsmotiv
demzufolge hatte er sich bei einem
Ostseeurlaub unsterblich in eine andere
Frau verliebt und wollte Renate ohne
Scheidung loswerden mal gibt er zu Agent
des westdeutschen
Bundesnachrichtendienstes zu sein Renate
habe dieses entdeckt als sie ihn zur
Rede stellte habe er sie mit Pistole und
Beil zum Schweigen gebracht eine
zugespitzte Version dieses Motivs lautet
der BND habe ihn sogar ausdrücklich zu
dem Mord
angestiftet laut den Recherchen von
Georg Mascolo hoffte Mischner wohl mit
der Rolle des vom Westen erpressten
Agenten ein mildes Urteil zu erwirken
aber er lag falsch Mischner war viel zu
nah dran an der Macht um jetzt auf
Verständnis hoffen zu können denn der
stasioffizier mchner war
Personenschützer für stasichf Mielke
selbst aber auch für andere SED
Prominenz die zwischen Berlin und
Wandlitz hin und her pendelte er plante
sogar im Detail Strecken und Zeiten
dieser Fahrten dieser Umstand führte
später zu einer noch wilderen Theorie
über den
Fall diese Theorie nennen wir sie mal
schießereithese hat ganz direkt mit dem
Machtwechsel in der DDR zu tun mit der
ganz großen Politik also dieser
Machtwechsel Klang im Staatsfernsehen
damals so heute trat das Zentralkomitee
der Sozialistischen Einheitspartei
Deutschlands in Berlin zu seiner 16
Tagung zusammen zu Punkt 1 der
Tagesordnung gab Genosse wer Ulbricht
eine Erklärung ab er war das
Zentralkomitee ihn aus Altersgründen von
der Funktion des ersten Sekretärs des
Zentralkomitees der SED zu entbinden um
diese Funktion in jüngere Hände zu geben
das Zentralkomitee stimmte einstimmig
der Erklärung des Genossen Walter
Ulbrich zu und beschloss auf Vorschlag
des politbüos seinem ersuchen
stattzugeben genossseewalter Ulbricht
wurde in Ehrung seiner Verdienste als
Vorsitzender der SED gewählt und wird
weiter als Vorsitzender des Staatsrates
der DDR tätig sein das zentralkomiteé
wählte einstimmig genossen Erich
Honnecker zum ersten Sekretär des
Zentralkomitees der SED
also wenn ich das mit heutigen Fernsehen
vergleiche dann ist das doch sehr
dröge ja aber in dem Fall wohl Absicht
Liebe Tony denn hinter dem einschläfernd
geschilderten Regierungswechsel stecken
Erich honnikers Intrigen mit Moskau und
die dramatischen Ereignisse vom döllense
in der Schorfheide 30 km nördlich von
Wandlitz knapp 60 km von Berlin entfernt
hier hat Ulbricht ein Sommerhaus und
hierhin fährt honik Ende April 191 70
mit einer bewaffneten Truppe er lässt
die Telefonleitung zum Haus des
Regierungschefs kappen und zwingt
Ulbricht quasi mit vorgehaltener Pistole
dazu künftig auf seine Macht zu
verzichten diese Ereignisse am
dölensesee gelten als historisch
gesichert aber was ich als these dazu im
Buch die SED in der er honik findet das
ist
abenteuerlich der Autor gibt darin einen
Artikel von Peter Ferdinand Koch wieder
der war Reporter der Hamburger
Morgenpost und zeitweise auch beim
Spiegel Koch sieht Wolfgang und Renate
Mischner demnach als Akteure am
döllensee mit tragischem Ausgang MKO
zitiert für uns nach dem Eintreffen
honikers und seiner Personenschützer
sollen sich am Eingang der
Sommerresidenz am döllensee dramatische
Szenen abgespielt haben die den
Amtsantritt honikers in ein völlig neues
Licht rücken würden plötzlich Hektik in
der ein Personenschützer der MfS
Oberleutnant Wolfgang Mischner mit
seiner Pistole auf die Angreifer feuert
die schießen zurück ein Querschläger
durchschlägt den Kopf einer zufällig
anwesenden Besucherin misners 30-Jährige
Ehefrau Renate tot nach diesem
angeblichen Schusswechsel zwischen den
Personenschützern Ulbrichts und honikers
soll der amtierende Parteichef sichtlich
schockiert über die Tragik der
Geschehnisse schließlich eingelenkt und
die Verzichtserklärung unterschrieben
haben
okay also die misners gerieten also in
eine Schießerei zwischen hornikers
Leuten und Ulbrichts Mannschaft wilde
Story leider bis heute auch völlig
unbewiesen umstritten ist bis in die
Gegenwart übrigens auch wie genau es zur
Todesstrafe für Mner kam Georg Mascolo
schrieb 1999 im
Spiegel als der protzess im Mai 1972 vor
dem militärstrafsenat des obersten
Gerichts der DDR begann stand das Urteil
längst fest Generalstaatsanwalt Josef
Streit hatte am 10 Februar bei honniker
angefragt ob er die Todesstrafe
beantragen könne und noch am gleichen
Tag die Zustimmung des späteren
Staatschefs erhalten anders schildert es
18 Jahre später Klaus beling in seiner
Kriminalgeschichte der DDR Erich
honniker war ein Gegner der Todesstrafe
im Frühjahr 1972 informierte ihn
Generalstaatsanwalt Streit über den Fall
Mischner ich beabsichtige die
Todesstrafe beantragen zu lassen ich
bitte um
Zustimmung das Urteil sollte also wie
auch in anderen Fällen geschehen rund se
Wochen vor Prozessbeginn bestätigt
werden doch Erich honniker machte einen
dicken Strich an den Rand und schrieb
nein daneben trotzdem wurde Wolfgang
Mischner am 19 Mai 1972 zum Tode
verurteilt und im September 1972 in
Leipzig hingerichtet
der neue sedchef hatte es in diesem Fall
nicht vermocht sich als Gegner der
Todesstrafe
durchzusetzen soweit die Darstellung zur
Strafe in diesem Fall und soweit die
Geschichte von Renate und Wolfgang
mchner erst 9 Jahre nach der Exekution
des gefallenen stasiengels wurde in der
DDR zum letzten Mal die Todesstrafe in
Ostdeutschland vollstreckt ebenfalls an
einem den die DDR als Verräter sah am 26
Juni
1 exekutierte man in Leipzig den Stasi
Hauptmann Werner Teske abgeschafft wurde
die Todesstrafe offiziell
1978 also z Jahre vor dem Untergang der
DDR und damit sind wir am Ende unserer
heutigen Ausgabe angelangt wir empfehlen
euch noch zwei weitere spannende Fälle
aus der ddrzeit hier bei Tat Deutschland
einmal Erwin hagedun die Kinder aus dem
todeswald und Carmen kleem der letzte
Mord der DDR und wir danken euch
natürlich fürs zuhören wenn ihr uns was
schreiben möchtet dann geht das auch
seit neuesten per WhatsApp die Nummer
haben wir euch in die showotes gepackt
danke fürs zuhören und bis zum nächsten
mal eure Toni und euer
mer dir hat diese Folge von T
Deutschland gefallen du bekommst von
True Crime einfach nicht genug dann hör
jetzt in unsere weiteren Folgen rein
hier warten mehr als spannende Fälle auf
dich wie das Verschwinden von Rebecca
Rusch der Prozess gegen OJ Simpson oder
die Entführung von Sela Hermann wir
hören uns bei Tat Deutschland